- Oh my gosh.
- You know, I gotta say,
Billy Porter covers one of your songs.
- Oh.
- And you clap
and you love it. And I
recorded underneath the tree
and tried to release it
on my own record label
and you sent me a cease and desist.
- No, I did not.
- Unbelievable.
- I did not. But I will
do that duet with you.
(laughs) I just thought
it was unbelievable.
- That was incredible.
- It, it's amazing how a
song can completely transform
into a different vibe.
- It was amazing,
it was amazing.
- Anyway, I love it.
And now I'm just get gonna feel boring
when I sing my version, but whatever.
Um, What the hell, man, you
won 'Celebrity Jeopardy'.
- The mind, oh thank you, thank you.
- Are you one of these people
that just retains useless knowledge
and you're good at it? Like
did you have to study for this,
like train for this?
- I do retain useless
knowledge, very useless.
I like forget my mom's birthday sometimes
but I can tell you who
won best actor in 1982.
- Okay. Greatest year ever.
- Ben Kingsley.
- Cause I was born when?
- Oh.
- Yeah just saying.
- That's a pretty good year, um,
but, but I did train, I
watched Jeopardy a lot,
I've been watching it since I was a kid.
But I would practice with a pen
and practice clicking in.
- To click in.
- Yeah. I looked really
cool when I did that thing.
- It is that's the part,
even when we play on here,
it's the, it's sometimes
how quick you are.
- It's, it's, it's timing.
It's timing and a little
bit of knowledge but...
- Yeah, a lot of, a lot
of bit of knowledge.
- A lot of useless knowledge.
- I actually found this out too,
in high school you were on a trivia team.
- We were, we were.
- I didn't even know that,
that didn't exist in my school.
Or maybe it didn't. I just
wasn't even smart enough
to know about it.
- Well, we didn't have football,
but we had Scholastic ball.
- I am Texan. So we had football.
- You're Texas. Yeah,
north side of Chicago.
Uh, but we were, we had
the Scholastic ball team
from the Latin School of Chicago.
We were the 1994 Illinois
State Champions. What?
- So you're welcome.
(both laughs)
- I was not the best
guy on the team though.
I was like the fourth best.
- Okay, well, why don't you
sit in that picture saying
- Yeah, where are they now?
- Who's on top now?
- Yeah. They're all
engineers and brain surgeons.
- That's great. Pop quiz.
- All right.
- Pop quiz. I'm gonna do
pop quiz all the time.
You're ready. What's
the capital of Oregon?
- Uh, uh, um, uh, uh, not Portland.
It's not Portland.
- Nope.
- It's, it's Olympia.
- Too obvious.
(buzzer buzzes)
Taking your trophy.
- Woo.
- Well, there's more Illinois
stage champ level trivia
where that came from.
It's gonna be constant.
- Let's go.
- Because once you win something,
I'm just gonna challenge
it the entire time.
- (laughs) Good. I'm ready for it.
- So just beat you back now
into our level.
- Please please.
- Alright, so just a
little something. Pop quiz.
(audience cheering)
What's the name of the largest
venomous lizard in the world?
Why am I '900' voice?
- The largest venomous lizard?
- Yes.
- Uh, uh, I would have to,
I mean, I don't know if they're venomous.
Komodo dragons are the, are the largest.
- Yes.
- Komodo dragon.
(audience cheers)
- You got your trophy
back. You got it back.
You got it back.
- It was a close one.
- All right. All right.
Which is also cool that
like a dragon exists.
- I know. Have you seen that
they look like dinosaurs?
- I know.
- They're terrifying.
- I just want someone to film
like a Barbie, like on one
and be like Khaleesi like,
you know what I'm saying?
'Cause it's a draft for sketches.
Anyway, you talked a lot
about your family the
last time you were here.
So how are your girls doing?
- The girls are great.
They are getting bigger and bigger.
Our new thing we're kind
of worried about is they,
they're singing songs, now
they're sharing content
and which is fine but one
is nine and one is four.
And so I have a four year
old right now who's running
around the house singing
'Unholy' by Sam Smith.
(audience gasps)
Yeah, yeah I can patronize.
- Those are great lyrics.
- Great lyrics for a club.
- For a four year old.
- For, yeah. I'm 46 and I've
been okay to listen to them.
But I have a four-year old
walking around the house
like daddy got caught
cause he is popping it.
And I'm like, daddy didn't pop anything.
He didn't pop anything.
He didn't go to a body shop.
He's not doing, daddy made dinner.
- Daddy was at home.
- Da, so we need-
- You are not abandoned.
- You're not abandoned. I'm here.
We need clean lyrics.
We need the KIDZ BOP version
- The KIDZ BOP.
- Of them, you know like daddy
got caught at the donut shop.
- Yeah.
- Bringing donuts home.
- Because he loves us so much.
- He loves a munchkin.
- Kind of, made up.
- Here's the thing, it
can, it can get awkward.
You know, it's also awkward. Pop quiz.
- Here we go.
- Okay.
What is the name? Oh,
(laughs) what is the name
of the simple sugar that starts with an F
that is a sweetener in honey?
- I, I don't know.
- Like a sugar,
what's like a sugary thing that usually
is "Oh this is found in the
ingredient"? Like Fru...
- A fructose.
- Fructose.
- Doesn't count. It doesn't count.
- It's my trophy, it's my trophy.
- Trophy's gone. I'm related to trophy.
- The trophy is mine again.
It came back this way.
- I need redemption.
- Wait, speaking of funny.
So I'm so excited about this.
Let's talk about the new
movie. So, or show actually,
so what is 'History of the
World Part II'? Tell Everybody.
- So 'History of the
World Part I' was a movie
that was made by the great Mel Brooks.
- Yes.
- The King, the GOAT.
Our most GOATed director.
And he made this movie 42 years ago
and we thought it was time for a sequel.
Enough Time has passed,
42 years and we, you know,
it's a movie that kind of is a, it's kind
of a sketch comedy movie that
kind of pokes fun at history.
Everything from, oh, the
Bible to the French Revolution
to the Roman Empire.
- Yeah.
- And we kind of wanted to,
you know, make a show of it.
So it's eight episodes on Hulu.
In each episode, we kind of spin the globe
and show you a place and a
time and like a funny sketch.
We have an insane cast.
- An insane cast?
- It's insane. It's like
Taika Waititi, Jack Black,
Dove Cameron, Zazie Beetz.
- Yeah.
- J.B. Smoove, like we have all these.
- Quinta Brunson.
- Quinta Brunson,
Tyler William James
from Abbott Elementary.
- Yeah.
- Just this murderous row
of people who were very excited.
- So funny.
- I like to think it was
because of me they signed up
but it was because of Mel Brooks.
- Maybe a little to do with it.
- A little, a little bit.
- So wait, speaking of Mel Brooks, I heard
that you had to get his like,
okay basically, right? To-
- We did, yes.
We had to like go and
pitch him like, "Hey,
we think this would be a good
thing to focus on in the show.
And this sketch and this sketch."
- How nervous is that conversation like?
- I literally couldn't breathe
because if Mel Brooks is like, no.
- This is trash.
- I have to find a new business.
I have to go become a
butcher or something.
Because if Mel Brooks himself is like,
"I don't think this is
gonna work with me and you",
you're out of the business.
- Oh man.
- You're done.
But he's such a wonderful,
just sweet, kind man
and was so excited that
we're kind of going back
and he had jokes that
he had been sitting on
for like 42 years.
- 42 years.
- You know, like we're doing a thing
about the civil war and we
have a sketch that, you know,
is about the Civil War.
And he goes, "Oh, oh,
Appomattox, when they're signing
the treaty and Robert E. Lee bends
over to sign, his sword should hit all
of his men in the balls."
And I was like, "Yes,
yes, we're gonna do that."
So, so-
- It's a little thing.
- It's a small thing.
- Yeah. I'm so excited.
It's such a great idea.
- It's so fun. It was
just so great to, to-
- Who in originally came up
with the idea that to do this?
'Cause it's like been years.
- Well, I think like Nick Kroll
is he had been kind of sitting with it
for a second and then he
brought Wanda Sykes in
and then brought me in with my partner and
the four of us kind of sat down.
I'm like, okay, let's
make this like the movie.
The movie is also streaming
on Hulu right now.
- And you're producing in writing.
- We produced it, we
wrote it, I did catering.
I was making breakfast
burritos every morning
for the cast and crew. I
did transport, I did it all.
- Welcome back, everybody.
Ike Barinholtz is with us. Give it up.
- Thank you. Thank you, thank you.
- So Ike's new show is called
History of the World Part II,
it's on Hulu. And just
like much of history,
sometimes on our show, we
get stories so long in Epic
that they need their own segments.
So Ike has one of those stories today.
So here's another installment
of "Epic Storytime".
(audience cheers)
♪ Epic story time ♪
The smile at the end
is what does it, Jesse.
So how this works is I get one question
and from that question
Ike will tell us his story
with the help of the book
of illustrations he has right here.
So afterward we may have
some follow up questions,
usually we do. But to get us started,
here's my one question.
Hey, Ike, what was your
most memorable experience
as a touring comedian?
- Oh well,
I would have to tell you
about the time that I was
in Europe and I was very,
very publicly embarrassed.
So this is around 1999.
- Okay.
'The Matrix' had just come
out, that's not in the book
but I'm just giving you some color.
I was gonna perform that night
and it was gonna be a really big show
with a lot of real comedians.
- Okay.
- People like Jason Sudeikis.
- Oh.
- The future 'Ted Lasso'
and Seth Meyers.
- Oh.
- Jordan Peele.
- Yeah. Okay.
- Some real heavy hitters.
- Okay.
- So at the day of my performance,
I had gone to the beach to relax.
We were drinking wine,
playing frisbee, taking naps.
It was awesome.
- Yeah.
- It was great.
Well, after one little
nappy nap, I woke up
and I had a little baby
headache and I thought, ooh,
I might have drunken too much wine.
No problem, it'll wear off.
But on the train ride
home, I was like, woo,
I am burning up. And
when I looked in my mi,
in the mirror, I clutched my chest.
Oh my God.
- Oh, you fell.
- I was as red as a fire engine
because I had something
called sun poisoning.
Yes. So I did what any
reasonable person would do.
I freaked out.
(Kelly laughs)
Now I had to do the show tonight.
If I missed the show or
if people missed the show,
it's because they had
bird flu or swine flu
or whatever flu, was
cool way back in 1999,
not because they drank too
much Franzia Pinot Grigio
and fell asleep on a frisbee
which is probably how one
of the lesser known Roman emperors died.
Stupidest Maximus was his name.
- (laughs) Stupidest Maximus.
- That was his name.
And my friends were like, why
didn't you put on sunscreen?
And I was like, I don't know, I'm dumb.
And they were like,
why were you drinking wine
at noon before a show?
And I was like, guys, I don't know.
Who are you, the cops?
The worst part of my sunburn
was on the top of my thighs.
And I read somewhere that yogurt helps.
So I had someone bring me some cold yogurt
and I went to the little
backstage dressing room
and I closed the door and
I pulled my pants down
and I started slathering
yogurt all over my thighs,
up and down, up and downs slathering.
(both laughs)
I must have gone through a good pint
of Greek yogurt, which, health
tip, is an amazing probiotic.
So I'm just sitting there slathering
in my white shirt, in my tie,
in my boxer shorts with
white cream all over my legs
when, here's the thing, guys,
the door to the dressing
room was very close
to the door to the
audience woman's bathroom.
And as I'm slathering myself,
- Oh my.
- This woman walks in on me.
- God.
- And I stand up and I'm standing there
with no pants on, covered in Greek yogurt.
And she looks at me and
she doesn't say a word.
(Kelly laughs)
She slowly closes the door and backs out.
So the relief I got from the
yogurt is instantly destroyed
by the worry of what this
woman is thinking about
when she's sitting there in the audience
and what she's saying to her friends
and what she's gonna say to her
therapist in 10 or 20 years,
the guy from the Mindy
Project, I walked on,
in on him slathering
yogurt all over his thighs.
I'm known for thinking very far ahead.
So back in the dressing
room, I pull up my pants.
And I don't know if you've done this,
but pulling your pants up
over yogurt slathered thighs
is not pleasant. So in little
spots you could kind of see
the yogurt seeping through my khakis.
- Oh my God.
- It's dripping out the sides.
And I don't even, I, I, I start,
I start looking for this woman.
I start looking for her.
And I don't know why.
Right? Because if I make
eye contact with her,
I'm gonna get more self-conscious, Kelly.
So that's when it hits me.
I don't know what it's
about my personality
but when I get hurt, people laugh a lot.
People love seeing me miserable.
And at this moment right now
is the most miserable I've ever been.
So I do what any
reasonable person would do.
I take my sunburn and my yogurt
and my abject embarrassment
and I walk out on the stage
and I make every person
on that stage laugh at me,
even 'Ted Lasso'. The End.
(audience cheers)
- Woo.
- I've, I've never,
I've never heard of, of yogurt.
- Yogurt.
- So it is a thing?
Have y'all heard of that?
- Have you ever put sunburn on a yogurt?
- Sunburn on a yogurt or?
- I'm sorry. Well, either
way you could try both
and see which one works.
Raise your hand if you've
ever put yogurt on a sunburn.
- Oh my God. You're one person.
- One, one lady. Thank you. All right,
do you happen to live in Holland? (laughs)
- (laughs) It's like-
- Listen, I don't know
where I got the information from, guys.
- Like hello.
- It brought me no relief
and only brought me more misery.
- That is amazing.
- That was rough.
- You know, I thought
you can survive anything,
once you do that.
- Once that happens,
I feared nothing now.
- Cake walk.
- I feared nothing.
- I love it. Okay, a
big thank you to Marcel.
Y'all, Marcel Acevedo
in our art department
for those illustrations
is incredible. It's truly.
You can see Ike's show
'History of the World Part II',
all episodes are now streaming on Hulu.